welcome to another episode on matrix
math today we're gonna be looking at
vector geometry another really important
and also just a really cool topic when
it comes to doing stuff with matrices
and in vectors so we're gonna look at 2d
vectors but they're all the same stuff
applies to 3d vectors as well so it's
just a matter of applying it with that
one additional ray if you're doing if
you're doing 3d so the math is really
all the same ok so the important things
of vector geometry so we're looking at
2d ones so let's say we have what's a
big circle let's make it way smaller
this should be good
so let's say we have a vector V and
we'll just we'll say okay so it's like
element a and element B so it'll look
something like that and let's let's do
some addition and subtraction and I'll
basically just show you how it works so
it let's say this is a a 2 to 4 vector
now the way we would do this is we map
it out on a standard standard little
graph and when you're just looking at a
vector like this you assume the origin
point is 0 0 and then you plot it as
usual where this is the X and this is
the Y so this would look a little
something like and I'm gonna sort of
ballpark this on 2 3 4 so we'd go over
to on the X and up 4 1 2 3 4 so there
would be the other point and then from
there we can make our vector so there's
our vector V and so it goes from 0 2 to
4
there we go and that's of course zero
zero so one of the important things
about this is the magnitude you often
want to know the length of this vector
and for reasons I'll explain as we get
further along in the video so if we're
looking at magnitude magnitude or the
length super important when you're doing
programming especially 3d stuff your
option just want to make a vector from
one thing to another thing and if you
want to know how far away it is you want
to calculate the magnitude so the
magnitude you just doing you rid of that
there the did we talked about this last
video I feel like we did I mean let me
double check here yeah yeah we did so
the magnitude of course and just as a
refresher it it comes in the form of
these two bars around the thing that
signifies magnitude of V and then you
just take all these elements square them
and take the square root so last video
we went over this I don't think it has
any views yet but you know such as the
case you basically square all these and
then you take the square root of it so
we'd get something like okay that's four
plus eight let's see there's a four
there's an eight so we get twelve we get
square root of 12 and if you pop that
into a calculator twelve square root
oops it equals three point four six so
you can use that length of three point
four six to do any further calculations
of length now what's cool about this is
you can do a lot of stuff with
pull vectors and using just some basic
addition subtraction and magnitude so
let me just show you that I'm gonna
create a new layer here and we'll hide
that one we're on work on this new one
so let me just show you just a few
examples here and let's see I'll do a
graph in this bottom right corner let's
make it look nice and I don't need
enough and let's just say we have a
couple different vectors will say we
have we'll go with the standard of a U
vector and a V vector and U is going to
equal I don't know we'll say we'll get
some kind of random but low numbers so
we're gonna be easy calculations we'll
go with a 2 and then negative 1 and V is
going to be let's go with a negative 2
and a 3 that should be good enough to
give it a little example so we can plot
both of these boys starting at this
origin point of 0 0 and we can make the
two on C let's do some little notches
might make this a little smaller little
notches we shouldn't need to go too far
no further than 4 close enough no it
doesn't need to be perfect but it needs
to be perfect enough all right so U is
going to be over 2 on the x-axis and
down 1 on the Y so it's going to go over
there so that'll be U and V is going to
be negative 2 and then up 3 1 2 3 so
it's gonna be there so look something
like that and there's B
and now if you add these together you
end up with an in-between point so it'll
be somewhere around here and to get that
exactly you just do the uses to the
addition so so let's add them together
two and then a minus two we're going to
get a zero there on the X and then a
negative one plus three is going to be
two so that's going to be u plus V
equals that and if we plot that it's
going to start at zero it's not going to
go over any on the x-axis and it's gonna
go up to so it's gonna go about right
there so we're gonna have just two
straight up line that looks just like
that and yeah that's gonna be the result
you can't really see it on there I could
make a different color but being that
it's zero two it's just gonna go yeah so
it's gonna be right on that y-axis
straight up so as you can see it's sort
of a midway point I mean it's not a
perfect midway point but it's gonna be
somewhere in between if you have if
you're adding them together and often it
ends up it can't end up yeah just
somewhere in between just depends on the
numbers but where this gets a little
cooler is when we do a minus so if we do
u minus V then something else happens
okay there's one other thing I want to
show you too here but okay this this is
pretty cool because when you do u minus
V u un DUP with a
vector that goes from the end of one of
the points to the end of another point
so it looks a little something like this
and that completes a triangle now this
is kind of an odd example because it's
it's a very wide trying home it would
make it really uh oh what's this obtuse
a very obtuse triangle
okay so let's - these two - another two
ends up being addition so 2 minus minus
2 is 4 and then negative 1 minus 3 is
negative 4 and what happens here is you
start from the point of of the one you -
from second tone to draw the line
so you start from the tip of the V here
in this case then you go over 4 and
minus 4 so be 1 2 3 4 and then minus 4 1
2 3 4 and we get 2 right here so we if
we started from here and then got to
here we complete a triangle by just
doing a u minus V and starting the new
plot point of this 4 negative 4 from the
V and what you can start doing with this
triangle is you can well you can do all
kinds of new geometry math you can get
you can get any of these angles you can
get any of these lengths by of course
just the magnitude of any of them is the
length and once you know at least three
data points of either angles or lengths
you can start figuring out all all the
math and I'll put a link below to some
of that stuff - a web page that explains
all all of that math and gets more into
the triangle math but I'm gonna stay
focused on vectors so I'm not gonna
cover all that right here but it's
really important and if you're
programming or something or
or you just need to know it for a some
kind of geometry class or a trigonometry
class it involves a lot of sine cosine
Pythagorean theorem so basically if you
have two vectors you can start
calculating anything about it
using a triangle and of course that goes
to other things cool things too like you
can well it's a terrible circle but you
can take like the center point and you
can do circles however you need to you
can do the inner area which can often be
nice for calculating collision and
things like that and yeah you can just
do a lot with it there so those are the
main things I wanted to show you but
there's also just one other thing I
wanted to wanted to show you why we're
here and that's basically just some more
things magnitude well I think we've
covered enough with magnitude you know
how to do the magnitude you know how to
do the plus and - you know how to
complete triangles so based on that and
if and from the link below and just some
trigonometry stuff you can do pretty
much anything you need to do with just a
couple vectors and you can really work
that in as needed and I tend to think of
things from a programmers perspective
and this is kind of sort of how I'm
going over to so I hope you enjoyed this
video hope it taught you some things
about vector geometry that might not
have been clear otherwise and I look
forward to seeing you guys in the next
video don't forget to smash the like
button that helps with the YouTube
algorithm really helps my channel out
still looking to to grow and get better
if you have any tips or comments please
leave them below I'll try to respond to
everything I can I hope you guys have a
great day
it's Friday here and don't forget to hit
subscribe and the bell if you want to
see when I come out with new videos I do
coding rants I do a lot of tutorials and
let me know what else you'd like to see
- alright guys take care of yourselves
out there peace out